it's a journey dad Marcus has been
waiting his whole life to pack for this
weekend he and his son Theo will be
swapping Cardiff for Qatar and joining 3
000 other Welsh supporters heading to
the Middle East
I can't believe it really but we're
going out there he's amazing in it it's
just like I said for me as well I mean
I've been supporting Wales for 42 years
so you know I've seen all the
disappointments over the years the the
near misses and uh this is like probably
a once in a lifetime really and I think
every Wales fan is going is just going
to be on cloud nine when we get it
because obviously a lot of the other
bigger countries are used to qualifying
so I think it means a bit more for us
and there has already been plenty of
chatter among red wall members about
what to expect to be told that the
alcohol prices are really extortionate
so we're prepared for that
um but I think it's just the fact that
you know we just got to embrace it
really I think that the fact that we
qualify we try and focus on the
positives and having a party while we're
over there as much as we can how excited
is it to see whales in the World Cup
it's gonna be really good actually yeah
the excitement is building further down
the M4 Hugh Hudson and his daughters
usually follow Wales on the big screen
at home also be heading east so I'll be
dreaming of since I was a child and die
hard Wales fan Swansea City fan that's
all I've ever wanted to do was see where
I was at the World Cup there's plenty of
times where I never thought it'd happen
um so to actually be going is just it's
a dream come true once in a lifetime
probably
[Applause]
[Music]
it has been a long wait this will be the
first whale side to play in the
tournament since 1958. the last time
this station was in a World Cup Harold
McMillan was prime minister
additional 40 years away however well
whales do in this competition one thing
is for sure they have inspired the Next
Generation
it is so exciting I almost had a tear in
my eye at one point to you yeah it was
so good
very excited and why is that well also
because yeah they haven't been in the
World Cup for a very long time and I
find
hopefully they're gonna win yeah
Wales lost to Brazil in the
quarterfinals in 1958 on Monday they'll
play their first game against the USA
before facing Iran and England
whatever happens this time fans both at
home and abroad will be hoping to raise
a toast
to a Welsh Victory Dan Whitehead Sky
News in South Wales